hey folks and welcome back to reality
check and to the second part of our
special all about PC graphics settings
and what the heck they actually mean
last week we covered resolution
anti-aliasing vsync and tessellation but
now it's time for the sequel which I'm
affectionate Leigh calling Rapunzel be
heart rules
ambient occlusion is really all about
making fake shadows now in a perfect
world of game design lighting engines
would just simulate the behavior of real
lights using global illumination this is
what's used for animation in movies and
it works our shadows by calculating the
precise color of each individual pixel
based on the overall amount of light
that's hitting it now that sounds
complicated and it is which is why it
works well for a pre-rendered scene but
is generally far too processor-intensive
to render on the fly end games enter
ambient occlusion it adds fake shadows
where we should expect to see them so
how does it do it well first off let's
think about lighting in general and your
average game the source is ambient light
and this is basically a more simple
simulation of global illumination with
the shadows based entirely on whether or
not something is blocking the ambient
light source now this on its own tends
to result in a rather flat light with
less shadowing that you might expect
ambient occlusion comes in and estimates
where these extra shadows should be
based on some rather clever ray tracing
calculations simply put it measures how
much ambient light or rays are blocked
by other nearby things so if an object
or surface is blocked in by other
objects less light can reach it which
means the surface will be in shadow
creasy's corners hollows on the under
sides of things tend to have a lot of
ambient occlusion
so that's ambient occlusion in general
but what about SSA o and H Bao and H Dao
well s si o stands for screen space
ambient occlusion and was actually
pioneered by the folks at Crytek and
first used in the original crisis it's
basically all about sampling the depth
of other pixels around an area and from
that it calculates the shadow H Bao or
horizon based I mean occlusion is better
and generates higher-quality SSAO by
increasing the number of samples per
pixel but as a result it's a tad more
demanding on your hardware it samples
the environment at half resolution
though to lessen the power required and
what about H Dao you ask well honestly I
don't know I'm not a member of the
highland dancers Association of Ontario
and those guys have the best SEO
oh you mean High Definition ambient
occlusion oh yes well that's broadly
similar to H Bao except that it's AMD's
own version of ambient occlusion poof
well that's the complicate one other way
so let's move on to an easy one with fov
not POV instantly as some YouTube
comments on my previous video thoughts
POV eh
I wonder where you heard that one before
I mean obviously I am no idea what that
is I've never heard of it never what is
it price of vegetables fov or field of
view on the other hand is the extent of
the observable game world that is seen
on the display at any given moment the
wider the angle the more you see so does
this hit your pcs performance well it
shouldn't much if anything at all sure
there might be more objects on screen at
a wider angle but they're also slightly
further away so depending on how the
game loads and textures and should
balance out okay next up is DOF or depth
of field right now hold your hand up in
front of your face like this
and focus on your hands right it should
be all sharp and looking great but
everything behind it including this
monitor screen should be all blurry and
out of focus
that's because of depth of field
technically it means the distance
between the nearest and farthest objects
in a scene that both appear acceptable
sharp or InFocus now as a video producer
I work with depth of field every day
doing so lets you get that gorgeous
out-of-focus background effect of
photography so handsome and also video
check out this footage I'd shot for the
Nvidia shield review notice how the sexy
sexy tablet is in focus but the ugly
ugly controller isn't this is
aesthetically pleasing because it's kind
of how we see things in real life also
did I mention the controller is ugly I'm
pretty sure I did
you see when we look at a scene we don't
see everything in sharp focus at once
in fact our eyes have a very narrow
point of sharp focus just a couple of
degrees but they dart about very quickly
when we observe a scene painting in the
detail as they go depth of field can
work really well in games especially
ones with first-person view it doesn't
make sense for those trees all the way
off in the distance to be in focus all
the time for example also by blurring
backgrounds you can hide those nasty low
resolution textures from view to bonus
now I've seen depth of field implemented
to varying degrees of success it's a
staple of lighting mods or Ian bees in
Skyrim but it's a little heavy-handed
and it can be quite jarring to see a
blurring as you go possibly the best
example I've seen though is in
Wolfenstein the new order it's subtle
enough but works to great effect in the
interior sections of the resistance
hideout everything just looks gorgeous
now in terms of a performance hit it
shouldn't be too significant perhaps a
few frames here or there so if it looks
good
use it aah or an isotropic filtering is
all about tactical blurring games need
to find sneaky ways to run smoothly
wherever possible and one of the oldest
of these methods involves making surface
textures blurrier the further away they
are without anisotropic filtering
enabled the result is what looks like
hard cuts between different levels of
blurriness as you look across say a
floor texture texture filtering works
too bland
levels of detail resulting in a smoother
less noticeable transition between
detailed closer textures and blurry
distant ones there are other types of
filtering like bilinear and trilinear
but generally AF is king and can be set
to maximum without impacting your
performance too heavily okay well that's
about it for this episode but there are
still a number of graphics terms I'm not
a chance to get to grips with like
physics or pulse processing or motion
blur and others so if you like a part 3
let me know in the comments down below
or by sending me one of those newfangled
tweets I've heard so much about to add
kam fries Rob ok thanks for watching
see you next week
you